live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
dead is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
open phones this hour rachel cruz number
one best-selling author ramsey
personality my daughter is my co-host
today
open phones again triple eight eight two
five five two two five well rachel i was
right and i was wrong oh
i'll tell you i'll take both of these
yeah this is you're good
i was a hundred percent wrong i thought
that washington would never actually do
anything except blow v8 and
carry on about
student loan forgiveness
the president biden is announcing today
that he is actually doing it
i'm guessing that the fa that he's doing
that with an executive order and i'm
guessing there will be some legal
challenges to that because i don't know
if he has the legal right to do that
with an executive order i'm not a
constitutional expert we'll see about
all that but he is doing it the thing i
was right about was i was 100 sure that
this ridiculously failed presidency was
going to do a hail mary going into the
midterms and i knew i told you guys i've
told you guys over the air here several
times in the past several weeks that he
was going to do an announcement this
week the week before the student loan uh
interest rate uh
forgiveness yeah the repayment was going
to restart on august 31st i was 100 sure
he was going to extend that and announce
something
about some kind of student loan
forgiveness i said that was going to
happen i also said that when it happened
it would not amount to anything that it
would be a bunch of political crap and
when you read the fine print that
nothing would happen but this appears to
actually have some teeth so it has
something welcome what's wrong about
that and as we're speaking right now
though the press conference has not gone
live we've just seen what the white
house is releasing the details well
they've released some of it yes but i'm
curious here in the next few hours when
the press conference what what actually
the details of it and what ends up
happening because
it appears it appears that if you have
that
up to ten thousand dollars will be
forgiven if you make less than 125 000 a
year in student loans
it appears that public loans not private
public not private
um and one guy already tweeted and said
my mortgage is now self-identifying as a
student line so just to just let you
know um but
not working but i'm sorry uh but the
second thing that happened was uh if
you're if you're a pell grant recipient
uh meaning that you were in there on a
uh you were struggling you're at the
poverty level or whatever uh when you
went into school uh then you get up to
twenty thousand dollars for given if you
make less than 125 000 a year yeah this
appears to affect about 20 million
student loans uh i mean student loan uh
holders yeah and so out of the 43
million so it's pretty substantial so
here's our take on this
we've been talking about it around here
for a couple days because we you know
they telescope that this was coming
telegraph this was
coming in a sense
um
that
number one first and foremost if you are
a ten thousand dollar student loan
person and you make less 125 000 and
that's this is getting ready to be
forgiven
uh we're happy for you
we want good things for you
we're happy for you we we're glad you
got you out of debt as quickly as we
want you to get out of debt and we're
happy for you as individuals we're also
simultaneously
angry on behalf of the people who paid
off their loans and feel screwed and you
know why they feel screwed is because
they got screwed that's why they feel
screwed
and um we're also
angry that this is an obvious political
ploy when this presidency from an
economic standpoint is the greatest
failure since jimmy carter
we have the highest inflation the gas
pump will make you puke
your fill up your buggy at the grocery
store it'll make you puke your interest
rates on your homes are up the housing
market is slowed down we're in a
recession
we are we may be we were with the last
two quarters we were in a session we may
be recovering from a light recession
it's not much of a recession but it's a
recession which by god the economy is
not prospering
oh and they just passed the largest
spending bill in history
to add to this and this uh move of the
stroke of a pen of ten thousand dollar
forgiveness amounts to about 300
billion
with a b
more
debt so you people listening just paid
off all these other people student loan
debt
and your grandkids paid them off
and so while we are happy for you
individuals and we are this slide toward
socialism with this extreme left wing
nuts
uh is it's out of control
it's completely out of control
this is a failed presidency
the the democrats are going to have a
bloodbath at the midterms they're going
to get thrown out like no other party's
ever been thrown out and you can go and
mark that word down and if i'm wrong
i'll come back and say i was wrong like
i did a minute ago but if i'm right i'm
gonna say i told you so too
but it's coming
americans are sick of the wackiness
coming out of the island to misfit toys
known as washington dc
they're sick of it
and they're going to fire a bunch of
people's butts with a d after their name
and this guy this little move right here
is not going to save it
it's not going to keep that from
happening because everybody's pretty
aware that when you walk up to a gas
pump and there's a sticker on it with a
biden that says i did that and you're
looking at your gas you know i filled up
my truck i had you know when they cut it
off at a hundred dollars you have to do
it again
because the so i'm like oh i'm running
my my debit card in there in and out you
know people know what's going on in the
midst of this right just so you know
before we went on the air i was like hey
as we talk about this
let's do like a book about the american
and a little bit about the about about
political because here's the deal
regardless of who is political that's
the only reason it happened it is but
regardless of who gets in in november
that's not going to change your life
people listening like no it's not going
to change
what happened in november and who's in
washington dc they're all an island of
misfit toys and if you want to change
your life you have to believe in the
power of yourself and that you can do it
absolutely and you also also ought to
call your congressman and tell them
you're going to fire them because they
continue to make student loans that too
so what about the guy who takes out
student loans next week
we're going to do to help him
you you bozos keep making these loans
but they're so bad you have to forgive
them because americans are being
oppressed by you
this is talking out of both sides of
your mouth this is so intellectually
dishonest if you're so bad you have to
cancel them why are you continuing to
make them you should at least stop
making them before we start
start forgiving them
it's just intellectually dishonest and
it's it's an obvious political plan it
is yes it's a ploy yes it was a campaign
promise for a year and a half you've
been in office why did it take you a
year and a half if i make a promise i
don't have to wait a year and have to
fulfill it i can just do it it's just
like that god this is aggravating
well and it's just the whole industry
though because the whole industry is so
predatory so predatory and he's 18 year
olds you can't buy beer but you can go
100 000 in debt yeah it's just dumber
than crap well and the people that and
these kids too that like that's that's
the part of your first
the first part of what you were saying
of the individuals that are happy
because this whole thing is it is so
like student loans it it is this lie
that has been accepted
so stop it sure those of you that have
your loans forgiven we're happy for you
the rest of you we're pissed off as you
are
because you got to pay the bill
and nobody asked you if you wanted to
pay the bill
you just got told you're going to pay
the bill
that's not nice
it's bad politics the timing is
obviously politics
this is the ramsay shot
hmm
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
rachel cruz number one best-selling
author
ramsey personality my daughter
is my co-host today as we take your
questions about your life and your money
and before we do pick up the phones i
want to reiterate what rachel was saying
because that is after all the overall
stance of ramsay
is that
if i
the other problem with the student loan
forgiveness is it makes you feel more
dependent on washington for your
prosperity
and they have never been good at
delivering prosperity to you
you
are the secret sauce in your life
you take control of your life
you get up leave the cave you kill
something you drag it home if you're
sitting around waiting on washington to
fix your life
this is like asking the dmv to be
efficient
you know this is not gonna work your
life's gonna suck
so we want you to have an awesome
prosperous abundant
life
and that is never dependent upon the
government
they have never delivered an awesome
prosperous abundant life to anyone
except defense contractors and lobbyists
but other than that the rest of us have
to go make our own way
and
you know the more people's emotions and
psychology and spiritual leanings are
toward dependence on the government the
more your life is going to suck and we
don't want that for you we want you to
win the people that we know that have
wonderful lives that become baby steps
millionaires that get out of debt that
are outrageously generous that have
great marriages none of that was
delivered to them in an envelope from dc
because there's also
something to be said and we talk to them
every day on the show people that have
paid off debt
and the emotional process that it takes
and the sacrifice like the things that
are built in that process of baby step
two of paying off debt yeah the growth
there is something there that carries
you when you become wealthy and so one
of my fears is i'm like i just don't
want a stroke of a pen again
if it's you that has that ten thousand
dollars and it's done you know we are
here we want you debt free we want you
debt-free uh but also
there's an easy button that they're
allowing
this to occur and most people have more
than ten thousand dollars on average
it's it's 38 to 42 thousand dollars so
there's so much more and so the
but now they're gonna sit around wait on
the next wave of forgiveness like they
sat around weighed on the next wave of
biden bucks so the next wave of
um
ppp loans or the next wave of coveted
bailout of some kind out of washington
from both parties if you become
dependent on that
uh you've got to wean yourself from it i
mean you've got you got to get off the
off the dole from washington in order to
be prosperous
and um it's just it it's just a sickness
that runs really it's a rotten smell in
the air
for for the for the nation as a whole uh
for what drives our economy what drives
our freedoms
all of that and so
anything that just causes you to be more
and more dependent i mean i came out
against the ppp loans i came out against
all that stuff in covet i didn't take
any of it i told churches not to take it
because i told them it's gonna cost them
back later i i you know i tell people
don't get on the government dole because
once you break through that and you just
like ah man
you just become dependent on it yeah and
it's just
it's it's really scary all right let's
go the phones open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
kevin is in california hi kevin welcome
to the ramsey show
thanks dave great to be here good how
can i help
so i'm on baby step seven and our next
financial goal is to invest in real
estate
um it's going to be quite some time
before we can afford to buy something in
cash but i'm wanting to educate myself
on the process in advance and several
times i've heard you say that you should
never buy rental property at retail
value you should always get it at a
discount
and if there isn't going to be a housing
crash which i was expecting but you've
given valid arguments as to why that's
not going to happen
then how do you go about finding these
deals when the competition in the area
is so steep and so much of the
competition knows more about real estate
than i do because they're experts and
i'm not
um it's hard
but they're there there's not many deals
out there today but as the economy
continues too slow and the we don't have
27 buyers lined up every time but
someone puts up a for sale sign then
you're going to see more and more deals
happen
the other thing that's going to happen
is there's been virtually no
foreclosures for the last two years
because of covet moratoriums
and so there's a backlog of foreclosures
getting ready to hit the market
um and there may be some deals in that
pile
there may be some stuff that pops up in
that pile i don't know for sure but
there may be
um
the uh uh
but you know the first deal is the
hardest it's like the first team member
i ever hired here was much harder than
the
1000th team member that we hired here it
was much weightier that it was a
decision i wasn't used to making of the
the process and the steps it was very
very hard so uh but you know we're
always you know old buddy of mine uh 30
40 years ago that was a house buyer
um
used to say we're driving for dogs and
he would drive around looking for a
house it was a dog
that means the weeds are grown up the
gutters hanging off
the bushes are overgrown on the house it
looks like a an estate plan that's gone
an estate deal has gone sideways it
looks like a foreclosure that's happened
uh it looks like somebody you know
there's something distressed about the
property and so that i smell a bargain
you know when i see that kind of stuff
if everything's in perfect condition
there's not a blade of grass out of
place and an ocd member of the community
is out there picking every little weed
out from around their bushes that's not
going to be a deal usually
you know and so you're driving for dogs
you're looking for that you're going to
make contacts with estate attorneys
you're going to make contact with
foreclosure attorneys you're going to
make contacts with marriage counselors
whoever you can find in the area that
might know where there's a property that
needs to be sold well divorces cause
this i know i know and some i mean
you're a blessing if you come in and buy
a house and it helps people that are
going through a divorce yeah but not at
a deal i mean is it a deal it can be a
deal i mean it's
rather than them get you know messed up
you know and so get into foreclosure or
something so
um sometimes
you know that you know you just clean
those somebody's in a situation where
they just want the thing turned quick
yep and that's where these are you see
these little signs up we buy houses and
you know all that kind of stuff so
they're all offering 70 65 75 cents on
the dollar
and is that the formula you use
i used 70 cents in the old days minus
repairs when i was buying houses
and fixing them and flipping them or
fixing them and holding them commercial
real estate i'm a little different on
it's a little harder to do that because
there's more variables involved and we
mainly buy commercial real estate today
i've got a bunch of houses but they're
kind of left over from the old days
but um yeah it's a
just take your time
learn
and buy the deal and if you can't buy a
deal that means you're just not ready to
buy you haven't found it yet you haven't
looked hard enough and when i was doing
these deals a thousand years ago kevin i
was buying foreclosures for a living i
would go through 200 deals to buy one
it is not i mean even when i was looking
at foreclosures not all of them were a
deal
some people had more oat on the house
than it was worth and that's why i was
getting foreclosed on why would i want
to pay that for it
and so you know i'm scratching and
clawing through a whole pile of stuff
looking for a needle in a haystack and
that's what you're doing take your time
take your time take your time
because dude if you buy a 400 000 house
for 250 000
you know you made money coming out of
the gate which is kind of which is your
strategy for
investment make money make money at the
buy
make money to buy there's very few
pieces of property
i've ever paid retail for very very few
and uh i've come out on all of those as
well because they do go up in value too
but you know it's better to start out
ahead of the game from day one josh is
with us in charleston south carolina hey
josh what's up
hey dave i appreciate you taking my call
sure how can we help
well i'm looking for your advice today
um just a quick background my dad
introduced me to you probably 12 years
ago when i was in college
and
so
i guess i know your baby steps
and your advice most of the time
backwards and forwards but i'm just
finding myself in a position that i
really need your guidance on what you
would do if you found yourself in a
situation
so
um earlier this year in january um i
lost my father very some of me
and thank you um and so
i am
my mom's looking to me for advice uh as
far as what to do with
um the life insurance
okay we'll help you with that you hang
on and we'll come back to this break and
make sure
we'll get you some help on that
i'm so sorry for your loss this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today
open phone is a triple eight eight two
five five two two five uh we're talking
with josh josh is in his early thirties
his dad passed away in january and he's
asking what to do to help his mom that's
about how far we got in the conversation
josh i'm so sorry
well i appreciate it
what happened
what happened to him
you know the doctors ruled it a heart
attack
but it was something that he was fine at
lunchtime he walked into the ambulance
and
didn't didn't come out so it was
something that just happened that
happened very very suddenly how old was
he
57.
whoa oh gosh josh i'm sorry wow man oh
man yeah and so
yeah and so how much how much life
insurance did your mom get
around 350 000 okay
wow
that's it he had all of the debt paid
off
except for his vehicle which we're
working through now just to sell it
all right my mom purchased the car in
cash
and so now she just has the mortgage
how much is the mortgage that
the mortgage left is 225
okay what does she do for a living
well she was working
with my dad
so that has just come to an end as far
as the income from that
i'm in real estate i've been a real
estate last five years and so she works
in real estate with me that she's just
getting started with that
um so she should have some income you
know over the next 12 months um you know
maybe between
30 and 50 000 is what i would expect so
she's in her in her 50s as well for her
she's she's 57 as well okay
he he always managed the money just from
the beginning they were married 37 years
we've been together a long time and so
this is all really new for her so we've
met with a couple financial financial
advisors and um you know i just
i feel like
it's so volatile that i don't want to
you know encourage her to do something
where she might lose 10 or 20 percent
with with the market today it is
i feel like her mortgage is almost too
much to put on you know just to pay off
the mortgage i don't want to put her in
a bad spot
with cash flow but if she has zero
payments in the world it doesn't put her
in a bad spot
that is true
it doesn't take much longer doesn't take
much live when you don't have any
payments
okay
so what do you make a year
i made 400 last year i probably won't
make that this year but probably 250.
okay
you know
here's what i would do um rachel you
chime in anytime the um
i want you two to go through financial
peace university together
because it sounds like it's time for her
now to learn how to handle money
she needs the confidence the tools and
the confidence
that that competence will give her
and you go just as moral support
okay and i'll pay for it i'm going to
give it to her all right we're going to
put you on hold sign her up for
financial peace um number one number two
in while she's doing that i would pay
off the house
that's going to leave her 100 100 000
and some change i'm going to set a
portion of that aside as
the emergency fund
and i'm gonna sit down with a
smartvestor pro and i'm going to invest
the rest it's not much but i'm gonna
invest the rest here's what i'm counting
on
i'm counting on her being able to eat
because she starts selling houses and
that gives her plenty of money with no
payments
to exist
if that is an absolute
debacle and doesn't happen while she's
getting a different job
you make 200 000 a year it won't take
much to feed her
if she has no payments
that's what i would do
okay
and uh i mean you're making a couple
you're making quarter mil
if she makes nothing and you you know
you pay a few of her bills here are
there to help her turn the corner and
and because she doesn't make it in real
estate and she goes on to something else
but she can get a job and survive
and and prosper
at 57 years old she's got a lot of life
in front of her and no payments in the
world and the peace
in this time of grief that that paid for
house will give and the peace that that
paid for house will give her while she's
out trying to sell real estate it takes
some of the desperation out of her voice
when she's talking to somebody about the
kitchen
she's got a lot on her she got a lot on
her i'm trying to take some of it off
yeah and i would encourage her to josh
not to do
anything major for 12 months i mean
obviously paying off the house is a big
is a big part of it but
um
as little change as possible that can
happen for just her grieving process and
you guys as a family walking through it
i think is really is really important um
but yeah giving her the ability to know
that she has control now over her money
because
um we see it we see that story so often
right that
the dad takes care of the mom
financially she kind of knows some of it
but like he he does the nuts and bolts
vice versa or vice versa yes
and then when that spouse something
happens
um that other person
they don't have the confidence and so in
that that fear can be paralyzing so
giving her
the ability to know that she can make a
monthly budget
knowing that she knows and understands
the investing world you know to a high
level that she knows where she's putting
her money and she's being smart about it
and she knows she has a plan for
retirement like all these things um that
you look at in your financial life as
much of that that she can start to
understand and plan for herself
will give her peace because all the all
the question marks causes stress and
fear um and as many of those questions
that can be answered for her which i
think financial peace university does a
fabulous job walking through so much of
this big stuff
um but joshua are kind
you're good you're a good kind man
you're a good man you're a good son
um
and just for those of you that listen to
the show all the time we generally tell
people after the passing of a spouse try
to make no major decisions for at least
six months
maybe even up to a year so take the
insurance money park it in a cd nothing
fancy and just sit and cry for a while
and let your brain clear of the waves of
grief before you start making major
decisions
by the fact that she has now chosen a
career and gone out there after six
months and by the fact that she's
meeting with financial advisors and they
are telling her to invest the money
um and he's considering that that's what
took me to all the way to paying off the
house pretty quick
um because i you know she's she is
has moved into the next stages there's
proactive she's proactively moving past
and so you know if she was still sitting
there trying to figure out what she was
doing and i heard paralysis or i heard
grief was still holding her right now i
would have just said park the money a
little while longer
but not invest it
yes so that and
very rarely on the show do we say to
uh
reach out and take care of
family members and because most of the
time it's enabling situations right the
calls on here i don't think he's going
to have to no no well no and it's not an
enabling situation like if it worst case
scenario comes like what you said
she's starting this new career path in
real estate it's not working but her but
him helping her
there is a level of this generosity
piece of
the message of of when you
do well with your money right when you
handle it well
and you're smart with it there's a
generosity piece that doesn't have to be
an enabling piece of people in your life
that you love right well the point being
when i pay off the house and it leaves
just a ton hundred thousand bucks left
okay immediately what starts going
through his and her mind is how am i
gonna pay my bills if this doesn't work
well number one you don't have to sell a
lot of houses
to make a living when you don't have any
debt yeah it doesn't take a lot so she
she just plinks one ever so often she's
going to be okay
she's very unlikely to fail to that
degree
right worst case then i'm all the way
back right right she's got this backstop
yes of a son that's very prosperous
and as a temporary measure a
sustainability measure not an enabling
measure so you know because that's what
goes through your head when i take a big
most of your cash and not pay off your
house with it then you go oh god how am
i going to eat then if this doesn't work
out well you got to think it through
number one it doesn't take many houses
she's got to sell number two she's going
to get another job if that doesn't work
number three she's got the backstop of
the prosperous son so it's a 10 all
those are temporary things and very very
unlikely that she ever gets to any of
them probably what's going to happen is
this lady is going to step into her
stride and be a world-class real estate
agent
and it's the next stage of her life
the encore the bow after the curtain
call
and um the song you play after the
everybody thought you were done you know
and it's that's what she's gonna do
and it's gonna be a big deal and she's
gonna have a great life and it's gonna
turn out okay in a really tragic and sad
situation
this is the ramsay shot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every time you hear someone hear on the
air do their debt-free scream it's
because at some point they said i've had
it enough
enough i'm not living like this anymore
and when you get mad like that
and do what they did your life will
change
right now inflation stupid credit cards
man it's everywhere
stuff's killing you you got to start to
believe that you're not you can start to
believe you're not in control with your
money but the fact is you are in control
and you can control it and you can
control the thing that controls it and
that's you
the person in your mirror is your
solution and your problem
you go to financial peace university
we're going to show you how to change
your life and change your future
we've done that with this proven
step-by-step plan for nearly 10 million
people helping them get out of debt get
on a budget build wealth be outrageously
generous learn to work with their spouse
about money guys stop letting debt and
money stress control your life say
enough
and take back control
start financial peace university at
ramsey solutions dot com slash enough
ramsey solutions dot com
slash
enough
jordan's in raleigh north carolina hi
jordan how are you
i'm doing very well mr danji mrs cruz
how are you guys doing great how can we
help
um
so my wife and i had gotten out of debt
about two years ago paid off fifty three
thousand dollars in nineteen months and
now we have a net worth about a hundred
and twenty
uh the only thing that's still sticking
around from black when we were in debt
is our credit scores
and because we don't have any active
debts or active accounts they're just
going down and it's creating issues for
us purchasing a home when did you pay
off the last debt
it would be 23 months ago
something's wrong
never seen it take 23 months for your
credit score to disappear usually it
disappears long before that you've got
an open account somewhere
that's what i thought too until i went
through each of the three bureaus opened
up all my accounts they all say paid and
closed and i've even called each of the
three
bureaus
do you own a home now
no sir we're renting
is your landlord reporting
uh believe well no there shouldn't be
any debt because we actually got a deal
by paying 12 months in advance
but are they reporting to the credit
bureau do you know
you're not seeing it on there right
no sir
man
i'm shocked because usually this is
there's still a bad debt lingering out
there or an open account
you just didn't didn't get it closed
um and it's still showing up that it's
very unusual for it to go 23 months and
not disappear matter of fact i've never
heard of it before
um i'm not saying it can't happen i'm
just
it's making me scratch my head but
you're but you're continuing to see it
jordan go down worse and worse like
every time
you check it
yes how often is it dropping
um
i use credit karma so i probably open it
once a month just to see if i'm down to
nothing but it's probably once a month
will go down a couple points
just a couple of points
yeah like the graph looks pretty linear
two or three points a month
yeah it'll be dropping dropping like
yeah 50 points usually on average around
18 months jordan so i would be
uh i wonder if i wonder
is there something i should be saying to
the credit bureaus when i call them to
ask them about it
yeah um
ask them since you have no accounts open
why it's not disappearing
i don't know
i don't know i've never heard of this
before i'm not saying it can't happen or
maybe they haven't because they don't
publish their algorithms they don't tell
us anything
the only way we know anything is just
observing what you guys are all doing
out there
and so we're just not running into this
um
yeah
yeah i would want to know why that is
happening and i don't know why right now
i don't i don't know how to help you but
yeah your goal is for that stinking
thing to disappear what's it down to
uh believe the less i'll check today 538
was what it was it can't get much lower
than that without disappearing
that's about it
so maybe maybe another month or two
it'll be gone i that's my hope since i
don't know the answer to your question
i'm sorry but i
i do know that um
that this
you know usually six to 18 months it
disappears from the date of last
activity and 100 of the accounts have
been dealt with and are closed
now if you've got an old bad debt not
you jordan because you don't you've been
very diligent very careful but if you're
listening to us you got a an old bad
debt from 1972 hanging out there and
it's just still sitting there it'll stay
there forever
and that's an important point at least
to make jordan or that that you're
making in this that all of you on track
of paying off that as you pay off debt
the the mathematical equation of how
your credit score is calculated is based
on you
being in debt and paying on your debts
on time but when you stop accruing new
debts when there's no new types of debt
that's happening and you're paying
unless that you have less you are going
to see your credit score drop so some
people do freak out because like oh my
gosh my credit score and the only reason
that really is a bit is a factor is when
you're going to buy a home and the goal
which is not happening with jordan right
at this moment but the goal is for it to
become un like it's it's undetermined
you can't you there's no factors to
calculate the credit score then you can
do manual underwriting to get a mortgage
um so you can't get a mortgage while
you're on baby step two as you're paying
off this debt your credit score is not
going to be good
but we don't encourage you to get a
house anyway that's right that's right
so jordan i'm hoping yeah in the next
gosh yeah i hope it hope it wraps up for
you three four months if not i would
keep calling you know i'm gonna keep
pestering people and try to find the
answer to the riddle if i'm you but i
don't know the answer to your riddle so
i appreciate you pestering us though
we're go that's what we're here for
zach is in charlotte north carolina hey
zach how are you
hey i'm good how are you great what's up
hey i was listening to your show
actually this morning from yesterday and
i had a question to stop me in my track
um
lady paid off
dead free scream and her she had a house
that really prompted her to get into it
um like a flood or something and
so i'll tell you my story i'm about 18
months into baby step two i have about a
year left and 25 000 left on that
and i own a home and i'm trying to
determine if i should sell that home
because i'm in baby step two
do you like do you like the home
i do yes okay how much is your house
payment
uh my house payment's 800 a month here's
the kicker though uh it's a duplex it
was built as a duplex and i have a
renter that pays me more than that
for
and what's your household income
i bring in about 65 000 a year
okay
no zach
go ahead no you don't i don't think you
need to sell it no you're gonna be out
of debt in a year so no i mean some now
some people
choose
to go radical and some people listening
are crazy and like would live in a tent
to get out of debt as possible but we
don't we don't recommend you selling
your house
to get out of consumer debt now if your
house payment
is insane and a high percentage of your
monthly take-home pay then yeah you want
to look at the calculation because we
want to get you out of debt as fast as
possible and maybe house poor if you're
going to sell it anyway because you hate
it yeah you know then go ahead and sell
it and it just accelerates the process
but if it's a house you want to keep
five years from today you plan to still
be there three years from day you still
plan to be there then yeah pay it off
and hold it that's what i would do
every single time is not required that
you
sell a house you know no no it's not but
um
you know some people do it out of
convenience some people do it out of
zest and excitement and gazelle
intensity um but most of the time we
tell people if somebody sell houses if
they were gonna sell it anyway because
they don't like it
and if
um or if the house payment's too high if
the house is the problem mm-hmm and
you're a house 50 of your income it's
hard to get traction yeah that puts you
in a mess so then yeah we would dump a
house but house is the most
expensive thing that we own to sell
selling some mutual funds no big deal
selling a car a little bit bigger deal
but still not that big a deal uh you can
get another car i mean but but when you
saw a house you have to move
moving moving's pain in the butt when
you sell a house it takes up a bunch of
your emotional bandwidth a bunch of your
time
because you have to change your dresses
on every stinking thing you selling a
house and moving is a you know it takes
a lot out of you out of your family out
of everything else
it's not as
easy a transaction as most other things
so we it's the last thing i do is tell
you to sell the house
and in your case no i wouldn't sell it
that's simple puts this hour of the
ramsey show in the books our thanks to
james charles our producer andrew zack
ben
austin all in the booth making this show
happen i am dave ramsey we'll be back
with you
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash debt free screen
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw
as the status symbol of choice we help
people build wealth do work they love
and create actual amazing relationships
thank you for joining us
i'm glad you're here rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
thanks for being here triple eight eight
two five
five
two two five
gina is with us in tulsa oklahoma to
start off this hour hi gina how are you
i'm good how are you doing better than i
deserve what's up
so i'm actually being sued by a payday
lender and i would like to know how to
go about dealing with this
wow
life must be rough
yes a little bit
i mean number one you went into a payday
lender and then number two you didn't
pay them and then number three you
didn't pay them for so long that they
sued you you've been struggling a while
yes it was in 2016 and yes i should have
paid and i can't remember exactly why i
didn't pay at this point but yes now
they've
contacted me and are trying to sue me
and they're going to win
they're going to win
how much is it for gina um so
the actual loan i took out was for 400
and then it was going to be like 600
to pay back but now they're saying that
i owe like uh 2
500 for like court costs or things like
that well in five or six years worth of
interest
yeah because you haven't dealt with this
how old are you
i am 31.
how many other things in your life have
been unkept for this long
um there's that payday loan and um
i think i have some student loan debt
as well
you don't think you know
yes i know okay
and if you done anything about it or is
it just sitting there since 2016.
um
before the pandemic i had reached out to
them to try to set up payments and then
because of the pandemic and all that
i haven't made any payments when did you
graduate
um so actually i didn't end up
graduating i went to dental assisting
school back in like 2010.
okay what do you make now
um
what do you mean what do i make and what
is your income
um
like
30 000 a year
what do you do
i'm a cna currently
do you have any money
yes how much
i probably got about four grand in the
bank good
call the attorney that's suing
and tell them that you're broke
and you can't pay them 2 500
but you'd be happy to pay them the 600
or even a thousand to settle this
because it's such an old debt
and begin to negotiate and argue with
and you will find the person on the
other end of the phone to be a complete
twerp
but that's just part of the process
this is not this is going to be
unpleasant but it's going to be less
unpleasant than losing a lawsuit and
having them garnish your wages
yes and i've already i tried contacting
them via email and they wanted uh like
my copy of my pace
nope nope nope they get no information
i'll give you a thousand dollars cash
settlement in full
i'm not giving you squat
kiss my butt
this is how the negotiation sounds
okay
no you can't have anything you but you
need to get on the phone with them
okay so it's better to call not email
yeah yeah and just argue with them and
if you get any
if they are going to settle you need
that in writing before you send them
money and then when you do come to
agreement and they go okay we'll do 1100
or whatever it is you end up like 900
whatever it is you end up agreeing for
okay
then say i need that in an email in
writing and i will immediately wire you
the money
so two rules here
number three rules for you number one
deal with this
yes you've been sticking your head in
the sand long enough deal with it
because it's not gonna get anything but
worse same thing with student loans deal
with it
number two
get it in writing okay
it didn't happen if it's not in writing
it's a lie
they lie
okay okay
and they don't mind lying to you because
they consider you a liar since 2016.
okay so get it in writing number three
no electronic access to your checking
account under any circumstances
they're gonna say oh just give us your
account number and we'll clean out your
account is what they're going to do
then you want the money for rent
okay so no i will wire you the money
or i can send you a prepaid debit card
with that amount on it or something like
that but no electronic access to your
checking account and no personal
information
do not give them any more information
they have a phone number on you and you
can block that if you need to
but don't tell them where you live don't
tell them
anything because they're going to use
all of that as leverage to garnish your
butt if you don't get this settled
okay
and but deal with this
jaina there's a pattern with you
and you gotta break that pattern okay
for your own good for your own good
this stuff does not get better by by
ignoring it do you understand and do you
agree
yes i understand and i agree good okay
because uh you you get these things
behind you you got a bright wonderful
future
but not dealing with things since 2016
is um it's a problem
and then you use language like i think i
have a snow you know you have a student
loan this all indicates where your head
space is on this it's that and the the
proactiveness gina which obviously we
can't do for you or change your heart
and this or your energy behind it
um but when i hear people you know use
that language even it's like she knows
it's there she probably doesn't know
really how much specifically no yeah the
interest that's occurred when just like
like it's it's just it's kind of all
over the place and denial is not just a
river in egypt though i mean that's
really it's it's not it's it's something
that it's something that people actually
do you can't and so
[Laughter]
so yeah how do you spell that you've
gotta you have to you have to push this
through okay
and so the number one habit of highly
effective people in stephen covey's book
the seven habits of highly effective
people is they're proactive they happen
two things things don't happen to them
when you have a situation where there is
conflict and you do not get closure on
it whether it's financial conflict legal
conflict whether it's uh relational
conflict whatever it is and you don't
get closure on it it does not get better
it gets worse
100 of the time
it gets worse until there's closure
it just continues to grow and grow and
grow and grow and get worse and worse
and worse and worse it's a problem so
there you go open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five how
many times have you found yourself
saying one day
one day
one day we'll do this well your one day
is here it's called the one day smart
conference we're going to work with you
on marriage on mental health we're going
to work with you on success principles
and leadership we're going to work with
you on becoming a baby steps millionaire
world-class speakers thought leaders
best-selling authors rachel cruz dr john
deloney craig and amy groschel will be
speaking on marriage it's all day long
october the 22nd there's just a few
passes left at 39
for general admission dallas texas
october 22nd the smart conference you
don't want to miss it and it's almost
sold out get er done
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
go
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they're the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings with
free samples free shipping new promos
all the time you'll save even more use
the promo code ramsey to get the best
possible deal so today's question comes
from holly in tennessee
my brother and sister-in-law asked my
husband and i if we would take care of
their four children in the event of
their passing to me there is no higher
honor we have agreed but i'm worried
that i do not have
that i do not know the right questions
to ask about this potential situation
what should i be asking for besides a
copy of their will
we want to be as prepared
as if this whatever if this were to ever
happen
it's a good one yeah that's very good
the
that whole process is a
fascinating one to have to pick to say
okay you know because when you do your
will that's that's a big part if you're
a parent of where they're going to go so
yeah for me i mean i would want to know
you know the the financial
side in a sense of uh what their
expectations are
who's going to be handling the money
who's handling the money when do the
kids get a say in it you know because
you can put ages 18 21 do you are they
gonna stagger it to no
i would want to know their plan from the
financial from the financial side um
and then obviously
the
the moral side you know of of raising
these children that are not yours and
you know having that conversation of
what that looks like watching their
parenting style doing as much as
possible not to copy who they are by any
means but
um
to be able to put into place you know
different things but that's obviously
when
when or if that ever happens but from
the financial side yeah i would
i would ask i would ask some questions
for sure i think it's good to have a
copy of the will and it's good to have a
clear discussion on uh if there's any
uh is there any life insurance proceeds
or any other things that are gonna be
left to take care of these kids or are
you expecting us to feed them um
what's our what's our responsibility
that we just took on here
and um well you know we're gonna leave
it all into a trust and the trustee is
gonna be bob okay good that's i need to
know that and so and how much is left in
the trust i don't need any of it but i'm
just
want to make sure i'm able to do what
i'm supposed to do here
and then i would have them write out a
letter on
uh
what their wishes were as far as
parenting goes
you know and so
you know like in our family it would
have said something like
keep make sure you keep them in a good
local church stay plugged in
you know and that their spiritual walk
is developed uh and so forth
um
and you know we we did have a lot of
things like that tied into when you all
were minors
into the uh into the estate plan at the
time so but yeah that's very good that
they are that thorough uh to even know
who to ask and the fact that they're
doing a will that's amazing a lot of
people don't even bother to do that
which is horrible you people need to get
your will done out there um but then
you guys
what holly's doing here is just really
outstanding it's thinking about okay
what does this really mean
and um you know that's that that's so
much that that means that they pick the
right lady
you know pick the right person that's
good
david is with us david is in south bend
indiana hi david how are you
i'm doing great how are you and rachel
doing better than we deserve what's up
so uh dave i just wanted to first uh
thank you
because of your teachings and we
followed it
we will be and me and my wife and i will
be entering baby step four for 2023
so
so my question is uh two small questions
uh so i'm not really good when it comes
to the whole uh you know where to invest
for my 401k plan so uh
previous employers i had only offered
the pre-tax before
so now i started a new employer in april
and they have three options a pre-tax
a roth and after tax so my first
question is uh where should i put my 15
based on those three right and then my
second question is uh since we still are
paying on the house um how much percent
of our income should we put towards fund
money good for you
roth uh roth grows tax-free the best
thing you can do is get a match the next
best thing you can do is tax-free and
the next best thing you can do is
traditional
and so you've got um
and then i think it was
50 on the two through six yeah great
match now the matching portion will not
be roth it will be traditional by law it
has to be okay but the rest of it is
roth and do it all in roth as far as the
money that is left over after you've
done that in your budget how much goes
towards paying off the house early and
how much goes towards fun
uh if you do zero of one or the other
you're doing it wrong
so zero towards the house because it's
all fun no
all towards the house and no fun makes
jack a doll boy
yes it does
makes what
it's an old nursery rhyme
this is why i have you on the show so
you learn
this is the this is the hour of
importance saying that you've never seen
it slowly i'm not kidding say it slowly
jack is a dull boy jack
jack no fun makes jack available give us
all right now
david we're good all work and no play
all work sorry david yes but a dull boy
it's both and david you know when it
comes to paying off the house i think
it's always a fun exercise just to
map out and say okay what if we paid it
off in seven years how much how much
would we have to spend what's that take
yes yeah how much would we have to
put towards the mortgage to make that
let's do 10 years let's do four years
and you can kind of see and know your
over your overall budget for your
household and say okay well what's
realistic that we don't we're not
completely burned out uh but we are
being aggressive towards something that
most people just sit around wait are you
laughing at me is everyone still
laughing at me no i'm i'm i'm not
smirking they are in the booth but i'm
not
[Laughter]
they are unbelievable it's all dudes now
in the booth everyone listening doesn't
care but kelly used to be i used there
was just because yeah i kept like kelly
took up for anybody i mean kelly didn't
take it for nobody but kelly
and me
now i'm it's me against the world oh
bless you give me the world's smallest
fiddle out okay open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
skylar is with us in illinois hey skyler
what's up
hey dave this is uh great to talk to you
you too how can we help
uh so i have a question on upgrading a
home
we currently own a home
i have a mortgage on it we're looking to
make get a bigger house
we're currently
debt free
other than the
mortgage um
and i make i make about seventy four
thousand dollars a year my wife is stay
at home mom
we have an eight month old
currently and then we have another baby
on the way in february
hey
congratulations good thank you
so your question is right correct
so so uh i just want to know is it good
should should we pause investigating 15
or cut back on that right now to start
stockpiling uh for per down payment on a
bigger house what's your house worth
uh it's currently worth a hundred and
twenty thousand
and your mortgage on it is what
it's uh 75 you already have a down
payment
okay when you sell when you sell that
no i mean if you want to save more for a
down payment i would no i would do that
but i would not stop investing to do
that
okay
gotcha you know what what price range
home do you think you might be moving
to probably somewhere in the 200 000
range
okay well 50 000 is 25 down
okay
right
correct so you don't have pmi if you do
this and that's a good move so you can
make that move as long as your house
payment is no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fix you can
make that move now
okay
because you got enough to put down when
you sell your house is that making sense
yes i guess yeah uh if you want to save
up some more down that's okay too
there's no harm in that
but it does not require that you you
don't have a lot of margin a lot of
wiggle room in your budget but it
doesn't require you stop your 15 you've
just started saving you just started
investing i hate to turn it right back
off
i mean you're just now getting the ball
rolling yeah
and i want you to lose that momentum
open phones this hour triple eight eight
two
825-5225
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today open phones triple
eight eight two five five
two two five zak is with us in sarasota
florida hi zach welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dan rachel how are you great what's
up
um my sister wants to borrow
about five thousand dollars from my wife
and i about
um
getting
paying bills and and
just getting through life but she has no
uh budget no
nothing like that that you preach about
and we're just trying to figure out how
to approach the situation without
causing the rift and go about it
well it doesn't sound promising that
this five thousand dollars is really
going to help her would you agree
uh yeah it wouldn't no it would be more
yeah
later on and it's more for
legal things and
house and
rents going up as you know with
everything legal things what are legal
things um
divorces
she's going through a divorce
yes sir
so she wants to pay her attorney bill
pretty much
okay
why is she going through a
divorce there's just a rough
divorce and rough uh marriage and
getting through everything and [ __ ] it's
just not right for her
she tried to amend everything and it
wouldn't be
it's past it
and you feel like though she has a
pattern
in her life where you don't trust that
yeah so you so you're you're calling us
but you know in your heart
probably not
but you're wondering like how to even
communicate that or
correct how can we best help okay how
much money do you guys have
oh we're debt-free
how much money do you have
um
500
thousand dollars
yes sir okay
and how much do you have like in uh
savings and checking and so forth you
get your hands on
about 300 000
okay
that's going towards our home that's
that's already
invested money into our primary
homestead home in florida
i'm sorry is that cash in a checking
account or savings account or you've
already paid yeah that's that's now
that's where we're building right now oh
you're building and the money is for
your building i got you correct this
money's earmarked for your home
but five thousand dollars won't mean you
don't get into the home if you use five
thousand dollars so five thousand
dollars your life isn't
as big a deal as it is in her life
well so here's the thing um
no i would not i would never under any
circumstances
loan anyone money
particularly people i love
because it changes the nature of the
relationship to borrow her slave to the
lender the odd thing is she will end up
resenting you
for this later
because she will feel like a slave and
she won't even know why it's just weird
and so uh but what i would be willing to
do is to give it to her
under certain circumstances
if i am participating in her
healing and moving towards
sustainability
fine if i'm participating in chaos which
is what her life appears to be
if i'm participating in irresponsibility
disorganization
and no plan whatsoever to change that
then i'm just giving a drunk a drink i'm
an enabler
that's really not an act of love then
you're right yeah if you love me you
would give me the money and not require
me to change no
the fact that i'm requiring you to
change is part of the gift is because i
love you
as a matter of fact it's the only act of
love in the whole process
so does she live in your town
yes okay
she does um
i recommend you and your wife sit down
with her and have a cup of coffee
and your wife doesn't need to say
anything because she'll end up being the
bad guy not because she's her opinion is
not valid but because i don't want her
to be the bad guy this is your sister
okay
but your wife
my wife i'm sorry go ahead she asked my
wife for the money first and then my
wife told me about it yeah but she went
to her first yeah that doesn't matter
you sit down with the two of you so you
show a unified front and you say listen
here's you got a lot of pain in your
life i'm sorry for what's going on i
want to be a help to you we will not
loan you the money
but i will give you the money under
these circumstances
you're going to go through financial
peace university you're going to get on
a budget
you're not going to borrow any more
money you're going to get and keep a job
and you're going to get in a position to
pay your bills and be a responsible
adult for the rest of your freaking life
and this is your brother talking to you
because i love you
you can thank you and she's likely going
to say no thank you
or she's going to say yes okay i can do
that and in our heart of hearts probably
wants to because everything you just
listed out
sounds good
and then when you get in the middle of
it or you start it
and it and then and then it goes off so
that's my thing a little bit about the
strings attached with the money like i
totally understand what you're saying
but also
he can't make her do those things so if
you go about that which i'm not saying
is is wrong because what dave just said
but also zach like you have to
emotionally let go
that you you can't force her to do
anything you can suggest and and but
you're going to give her the money i'm
not going to give her the money up front
until she does something she's going to
i'm going to see some action okay yeah
that's fair does she work
uh yes she works for herself she's
self-employed does she making money she
have kids too sorry
yes there are children involved
man
she makes money yes but it's all going
towards bills and
everyday living expenses rent food does
she make enough to support the household
after she's divorced
if you help her with five thousand
dollars
no okay so she doesn't make any money
correct she has nothing to say
compared to her lifestyle too she needs
a job
and to maybe move i mean like seriously
the
if your lifestyle is at a certain point
if this was not your sister and you sat
down and just looked at the math and
told her what to do with the math that's
what you need to tell her to do
yeah yeah i got to get your income up i
got to get your out go down that means
you probably can't live in this house
it's too expensive or you can't uh
continue to work this
crummy small business idea that is not
really making you any money and it's an
excuse for you to not work really and so
you've got to go like nine to five and
the kids are gonna be in daycare and i'm
gonna help you with all that we're gonna
coach you we're gonna be your biggest
cheerleaders and we're gonna walk
alongside you and uh and i need the
money for an attorney okay i'm gonna pay
the attorney directly
i'm not giving you the money and uh and
i'm gonna be on the phone with the
attorney i wanna know what's going on
for the five thousand dollars i'm giving
or the three thousand dollar retainer
i'm giving him the two thousand dollars
is going to these bills okay i'm gonna
write the check to those bills directly
when the ramsey family foundation comes
into
someone's life who's having financial
trouble we pay the bills directly
we do not give them a check zach do you
think if you sat down with her because i
don't know what joel's relationship is
obviously never met but like when you
sit down with her
and say hey here's what we see just from
a math side this this and this and after
the divorce
here's the like like not like this isn't
going to work mathematically so
we're here to help problem solve to
figure out how to get your life stable
uh where you can breathe again and if
you give suggestions is she the type
that will she want to hear it does she
want help but she just doesn't have
anyone in her life to walk beside her or
not
it just depends on
how she feels at that time and sometimes
she just wants the money and sometimes
she doesn't want to hear anything but
the money yeah yeah
yes or no and the answer to that
question is no
if all you want is money and you don't
want any help
real help no i have no i have no desire
to participate in
you're crazy i'm not i'm not funding it
for you
when you decide you want to get things
straightened up i'll walk with you in a
process to help you get things
straightened up we'll pay for you to go
through financial peace university and
we'll give you the money but don't loan
our money
loaning your money means you expect for
it to be paid back and it changes the
quality and the tenor of your
relationship and i would not do that
i would love her well and be very
generous and give her money if you're
helping her
get traction
back to sanity and sustainability but i
don't want to participate in crazy and
chaos and fund it well
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show rachel cruz
ramsey personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five marita is with us
in syracuse new york i'm marita how are
you
hello rachel thank you so much for
talking with me today
sure can you speak directly into your
phone it's pretty muffled
uh yes is that better yes perfect yes
thank you
all right awesome um so i have a
question um about student loans uh yay i
have many emotions about what biden
declared today um
but i'll try and get to the point my
husband and i were in our early 20s we
have 2
375
left to pay off on our student loans we
have worked so hard to get to this point
now biden's declared that he can just
forgive it at some point but we know
there's a period of time before that's
going to happen would it be the right
thing to do out of principle to just pay
it off on our own
or should we apply for forgiveness once
that application becomes available to us
write a check and pay it off
don't wait okay
don't wait
um
the emotion here is so is so mixed about
the call today and and what they
announced
and
and i think the heart behind it is
relief well
we can probably go all around but i
think there's an element of it that is
to relieve people and you guys don't
need relief because you have the money
and
you got i mean and there and there is a
personal responsibility thing with all
of this too that you guys you know
signed this
uh and your names are on it and
uh the idea of taking money from the
government when you have it i just don't
i can't i can't uh
that doesn't say well doesn't say well
with me so
i'd rather check and pay it off don't
wait on them
that's a nice way of saying it marita
you um
you already knew that that was what you
wanted to do because it's who you are by
the way you phrased your question
and so it makes it very easy for us to
just agree with you and say yeah
yeah i would do that
um
you know it's not immoral
um
for someone to take the relief that is
being offered
but
there is a
uh
a moral obligation that you borrowed the
money
and to pay it back is not a it is a
values-based decision
even though you quote don't have to
unquote
it's a values-based decision
and and
you know
so you know on a macro level on a
nationwide level on a uh big scope um
somewhere where we have to remind people
that
the money comes
from the government comes from somewhere
in the 300
billion dollars
with a b a billion is a thousand million
that is three hundred thousand
million
that
the president is strutting around proud
that he just added to
the taxpayer's burden
if you are a taxpayer
and 48 percent of you are not
in america today a federal income tax
taxpayer
but for those of us that are our burden
was just increased by three hundred
thousand million
so that you could get ten thousand
dollars in debt forgiveness
um i'm happy for you if you got your
debt forgiveness
um i really don't want bad things for
you i want good things for you and i'm
not angry with you you didn't do
anything out there if you got debt
forgiveness but
the absurdity of this political move as
a hail mary to try to get back in the
graces of the good of the voters before
the midterms in a in a in a presidential
administration that is a complete
economic failure
it's just
infuriating
and it's all put on the backs of your
grandchildren because it's all added to
the deficit
three 30 trillion dollars in debt
already
and we add 300 000 million
to that in student loan forgiveness
while we continue to make student loans
and this is just equal it's just
intellectually dishonest
to continue to make the loans and on the
one hand and then turn around forgive
them on the next
because the next call we're going to be
getting
that we're going to get this call
because it's already running through
some of your heads
i've got twenty six thousand dollars in
student loan debt president biden just
forgave ten i'm going to wait on him to
forgive the rest is that okay
even though there's no announcement of
that or or indication of that or
promise of that or
but you know once you've opened the
spigot
you know folks are gonna con expect you
to continue to open the spigot like
trump issued by bucks during the trump
dollars during the covid and then
another set and then biden the bucks
came out and biden bucks and biden bucks
so once the once the all of your covid
problems were going to be solved by the
government instead of by your own hand
then you now are waiting on
these biden bucks to come through after
the trump bucks
after the biden bucks after the trump
bucks and it just keeps going and going
and going and going because you've
become begun to look at washington dc as
your source
when we were getting those questions
and we've gotten that question for over
a decade i feel like every politician
makes some kind of debt for student loan
forgiveness
well you know it was the fringe it was
elizabeth warren and aoc it was the
french wackos that were suggesting it at
first and then it got a little bit more
mainstream and this president is so far
left
so far much a socialist in his and his
approach to things that um
you know he had it on a campaign promise
took him 18 months in office to come
through with a campaign promise but the
idea is that touring during the 18
months but also
even just the idea of student loan
forgiveness that's been floating around
for almost a decade we've heard that
term because because in
very small pockets right you see
different things
um
but and we and we get those calls even
then like this is
actual facts on paper that it's
happening
but even just the idea to your points
floats in people's heads and when that
seed is planted
it's this idea that i'm gonna just sit
back turns you into a trust fund baby
and there's a
yeah
yeah i mean if you're sick if you're if
your dad is 60 years old and he's got 10
million dollars and you don't work much
and you want to just sit around wait on
him to die
for you to have a life
because you're going to get in because
you're going to inherit 10 million
it's the same dadgum thing i'm sitting
around waiting on i guess someone else
to fix my life
yes right the mindset is the same but i
think the feeling of debt and the weight
that debt carries on families though is
different than i just want to be lazy
and inherently like you know what i'm
saying i agree so yeah i get what you're
saying but also i'm like man there's
like this but when you when you say okay
i'm not gonna deal with this
right
and i'm gonna let someone else i'm gonna
i'm not gonna deal with this i'm gonna
i'm gonna wait on someone else to deal
with it and that's not marital and
what's interesting too we talk about
this all the time on the show of how
money your habits within money
are a lot of different habits in other
areas of your life
and so it's fascinating too when if you
become passive
with your money sitting back and letting
other people take it like
are you then passive in your career
in your marriage and your parents like
what healthier because you're one person
you talk about this a lot like you're an
like integer is a whole number we are to
have integrity you are a whole person so
you can't take one part of your life and
say
i'm going to be like this this and this
wait right like we think we can
compartmentalize so much and we can't we
are one person
and so even with that i mean i don't
have the science to back it but i am
curious
it's impossible to be highly ambitious
organized and disciplined
in your money
and
uh be completely opposite of that in
every other area of your life it's it's
or be or be highly ambitious and
disciplined in your career but be
completely undisciplined and physical
you know because the opposite is true
and the opposite is true which we hear
all the time that people are like oh my
gosh my spouse and i like we got out of
debt and it changed our marriages we
started communicating you know we even
hear health like i lost weight right
like all these other things fall into
place and so our marriage got better
of being passive in life
it's just hard i mean i think it just
affects other areas too so we just you
got to be careful you got to be careful
margaret thatcher said it well the
problem with socialism is eventually run
away run out of other people's money to
give away
it's a problem
it's a real problem
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
five two two
five anthony's going to start us off in
los angeles hi anthony welcome to the
ramsay show
hi how are you doing mr ramsey great man
what's up
um so my fiance and i recently got
engaged last august
and uh we've been fighting about the
cost of it i told her that i wanted to
pay off my debt first before we went and
tried to pay off a big wedding
and i just paid off my debt this month
and
with the wedding that she wants i can't
afford it with it only being six months
away and i've been telling her that i
don't know what is the price tag
sixteen thousand
the price tag is twenty thousand but she
we she paid six uh four thousand so
there's 16 left what do you make
uh about 30 40 a year
okay
what does she make
about the same sir we're both in the
military oh actually okay
i'm sorry go ahead with your question uh
and that's basically
so i was telling her that i don't feel
comfortable going back in debt
um but she basically i asked her to move
it back she said um if the wedding
doesn't happen when it's scheduled just
like that there's kind of no reason for
us to continue and i don't know if this
is something i should hold my ground on
or as a man
if i should make this happen for her
well the surface problem is that she's
choosing a wedding over you
which you're kind of involved in the
wedding so this is kind of oxymoronic
it's a little crazy
but then there's deeper stuff i mean i
would think though anthony there's other
stuff going on right i mean is it that
that that i mean do you have a pattern
of not doing what you say and she feels
like that this is part of it i mean like
is there is there other stuff or is it
really that simple that she's like if i
can't
have this wedding at this date
twenty thousand dollars
i'm done like is it was it really that
cut and dry or have you guys been
uh you've been fighting uh since we got
engaged fighting about what about what
specifically for me it's the cost of it
she says that um
i'm being greedy and this is something
that
people
you know pay for
and i've just been telling her i just
don't feel comfortable going in debt
there's other ways around it i've said
if we can push it back which we've
already pushed it back it was originally
supposed to be uh happening next month
but due to our finances from coming back
overseas we pushed it that's so
frustrating i'm like go get a mic go get
go go get married you guys have been
engaged for a year go get a marriage
certificate you guys go to the
courthouse go get married and then in
six months well yeah i guess that's
probably true i guess this would have
been like this is what i would want for
you though if it was in a healthy state
that's fair that's fair is to go do that
and then you can go do a reception
another time but there's but there are
there are too many red flags here let's
establish a couple things all right
a 16 000 wedding is not
too much
you're wrong that is a reasonably priced
wedding
and yes sir but you are right to say i'm
not willing to borrow money to do it and
i don't make a lot of money it's going
to take me a while to scratch that
together
so and in the sense that she's right she
probably
feels like you don't value her you don't
value the
ceremony and you're not you know you
don't
hey so or is being cheap yeah you're
being cheap when it comes to her and
that's probably hurting her feelings
that's probably where the fights are
coming from how old are you two
i'm 23 sir and she is
24 sir okay
all right so um the amount is not out of
line
the process and everything around the
thing is out of line
when you hear
uh if i don't get my wedding my way
uh i'm out of here well guess what
you're gonna hear that the rest of your
life
if i don't get this car i'm out of here
if i don't get this couch i'm out of
here if i don't if you don't budget for
my nails and my hair i'm out of here so
you know you're not an atm machine
you're a husband potentially
okay and it's not a matter of as a man
it's a matter of we need to be as two
grown-ups in uh
in
uh agreement in alignment of how we're
going to live our lives and if we can't
establish that i'm not going to borrow
money
and so if you
if you demand that we do things that
require that we borrow money then we
don't need to get married because that's
going to be in inconsistent and we're
always going to be fighting and it's not
good it's going to lead to another
divorce or a divorce in the future so we
don't need to do that but if we can be
in agreement that the amount is
reasonable but the process the ultimatum
i'm out of here if i don't get what i
want spoiled little brat routine um or
the process of i demand you borrow money
to make me happy um and again that's
against your values then yeah this is
over she needs to just check out
so uh so if i were in your shoes
obviously you guys are in love or you
think you are
um
i would try to sit down with a pastor a
chaplain you're in the military get a
chaplain to sit down with you a good
christian chaplain
is the only way i know to get at it um
so
or go see a pastor at a local church and
sit down and try to get some coaching
and some counseling some relational
input on how you guys deal with this it
sounds like you're talking at each other
instead of with each other
yes sir like she's not hearing how
important this is to you and you're not
hearing how important this is to her and
so it comes down to
you have to borrow money to make me
happy that's probably not what she
really means
i hope she's not that immature and
shallow
she's probably just saying
dude this has been going on forever
you know it's been going on forever and
i don't i don't see how we're ever going
to get there
and i can't you know if we don't borrow
money i don't know how we're going to
have 16 000 i don't know how we're gonna
have a decent wedding but a sixteen
thousand dollar wedding with both of you
working
and household income would be the
equivalent of about seventy thousand is
not unreasonable yeah it's not if you
have the cash and can put the cash
together um by the way during this year
while you were getting out of debt she
put a whole four thousand dollars
towards this
where's her
if she makes the same amount of money
uh it's not your obligation to man up i
mean you're over here cleaning up
something else yeah so and i don't
necessarily believe you have to be out
of debt to be married either by the way
that's another thing i would throw at
you so we do want you to live out of
debt and debt free because we believe
that's the best way you're gonna have a
great
life but it's not yeah you're not
required to be debt free to start a fan
have a baby or get married like these
big life things but you don't need to be
in agreement and right now the big the
big red flags are you're not in
agreement and if this does come down to
the ultimatum of
you either borrow money
or i'm out of here then you know
i'm gonna miss her
gonna miss you
that's what it comes down to
she's walking away yeah the whole
country song
allen jackson sacramento oh brad paisley
no
brad paisley is a fishing song yeah i'm
i'm going to miss her too yeah there's a
lot anthony yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
well we're already halfway through
august can you believe it next week
every store will probably have christmas
out
if fall means that you're planning to go
broke until tax season
uh make this year the one you say enough
is enough
you know let's stop
say i've had it i make too much money to
be this broke the ramsey 10 sale is back
for a very limited time to help you take
control of your money now's your chance
to get up to 83 off our number one
best-selling books and tools like the
total money makeover
like love
your life not theirs like know yourself
know your money by rachel cruz those are
both number one best sellers our team
isn't stopping
get help solving your money worries and
it should not be overwhelming
that's why we're also offering a free
financial coaching call with any
purchase talk with a ramsey preferred
coach about your specific money
questions and plans and they'll help you
make goals and stick to them so you can
go from i've had it to i've got this
10 bucks
doesn't get much most places but right
now at ramseysolutions.com
gets you a lot the ten dollar sale
ramseysolutions.com
check out all the best-selling books
that are available for you
up next is going to be evan in san
antonio texas hi evan how are you
hello mr ramsey how are you better than
i deserve how can we help
well
my husband and i were coming up on five
years on friday congratulations
yeah thank you
we're still new at this
however we um we have been on this
journey
to getting debt free but we're stuck on
baby step number two
because we've had so many transitions so
i wanted to know would it be okay for me
to take
my
retirement money that i have to put
towards our debt
since we're transitioning again
and that way we would be out of
the debt but we would be able to
potentially use the rest of our money
towards retirement
well if you do that evan
no well let me say this no we would not
recommend doing that because if you did
that the amount of penalties the amount
of fees that are associated with
retirement accounts
uh before the age you it's it's not
worth it it's not smart not smart do you
guys have any other investments that are
not tied to retirement any other just
mutual funds or
do you have cds or anything in any other
account
no ma'am we don't we have um
we
so one of our transitions is that we
recently moved from another state
so we we had this move because of
a job offer that my husband had and he
accepted it
so
it was a pay increase for him
what's your household income
so for household income right now we're
at about seventy thousand and how much
debt do you have in baby step two
so in baby step two we have right around
17
and how much money are you putting in
your 401k
um it's coming out now of his pay
because i'm no longer working yeah how
much money is going into his 401k what
percentage
i'm not exactly sure
and how much how many times a week do
you all go out to eat
um i cook
no how many how many nights a week do
you go out to eat
um
not not very often how many nights a
week do you go out to eat
um
i'm not going we don't i cook every
night you never go out to eat
not every night he grabs something like
on the way to work so
he works
yeah he works
and then i have the kids so i i was i
was teaching but um i had a baby yeah
good so i have a newborn so i'm not
congratulations that's awesome thank you
and um
when was the last vacation you guys had
oh my goodness
we haven't had a vacation as a matter of
fact he's working on our anniversary
it's friday and he's working
okay so he he what are the transitions
you're referring to having a baby moving
uh
no
we had um
in 2020 i had um a baby a baby boy
and then he
had to resign his position at his job so
he wasn't working for a time he was
doing like um like list and things like
that but because i was a teacher i was
able to still work during that time
um so we were down to one income in 2020
because he wasn't able to work and then
i had the baby okay let me tell you what
i think what i hear happening and you
tell me if i'm wrong okay
okay a lot of life is coming at you
job changes
babies
covered
working not working
um
a lot of things are happening and you've
not been paying attention to the details
of the money while all these different
things were happening because you were
your mind was so full of those other
things
because your answers are incomplete when
i ask you very direct questions
yeah and so um i think you kind of feel
like a hamster in a wheel don't you
yes yeah and you're thinking that the
magic bullet is to take the money out of
retirement instead the magic bullet is
to get to the bottom of all of this and
the two of you sit down
with the kids in asleep
and sit down and do a detailed budget
and lay out some dreams on paper like
knocking out this 17 000 what have we
got to do to do that and we're going to
tighten up the food budget and we're
going to pick up work here and there and
do what we can we're going to look
around here for what we can sell and we
now have a new goal in addition to
cleaning diapers and feeding screaming
toddlers we now have a new goal and that
is to knock this 17 000 in the head but
the trick is what will happen while you
do that is the two of you will learn to
work together and work a budget and work
a system and happen to the money while
life is happening instead of the money
kind of gets parked on the side while
life is happening and you've got to get
up in its face and make it behave
right that that that's the answer to
your equation and that's a lot more
valuable than seventeen thousand dollars
and it's a lot more valuable than your
retirement account being
cleaned out no please don't clean out
your retirement because this debt is a
symptom of you guys not having focused
concentration detailed diligence
on this subject because of all that's
been coming at you but hey
you got two littles two tiny littles
i've had a lot and they're like a
full-time that's a big deal i mean
they're overwhelming they are they need
a lot they need a lot they don't do much
for themselves at this age and so you
know
and i and i really do see the next 12
months of your lives
uh getting better being more simple
right like what you just laid out for
the last two years it has been a lot and
gaining traction in the middle of all
that
uh would be really difficult and so i
wouldn't like
don't feel shame or embarrassment
because of that but also
to dave's point earlier
now that things are settled you guys
actually work on on your habits and like
what you guys are doing where your
money's going being so
so intentional with a plan
list it out know exactly what you're
doing have a timeline have a game plan
and you guys together do that which from
a tactical standpoint fifteen hundred
dollars a month on this debt we're gonna
be done in a year yeah we're gonna live
on beans and rice rice and beans we're
not going out to eat we're pausing
retirement challenge retirement oh by
the way you're still putting money into
retirement that's not what we tell you
to do we tell you to stop i forgot about
that i pulled that out of her and then i
left it laying there it's okay i'll host
the show okay you can you can you can
catch my slime
and uh yeah that's exactly right you
need to stop your 401k
during when you're in baby steps one two
and three you do not do investing
because you need total focus and you've
not had total focus it's all it's all
spread all over the place that's what
we're hearing talking to you so yeah
stop your 401k detailed tight budget
beans and rice rice and beans no
vacations no eating out we are going to
completely focus on this debt 1500 a
month and you are debt-free in one year
from today
that's all you got to do you can do it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today open phones a triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jack is with us in little rock arkansas
hi jack how are you
i'm doing good thank you for your time i
appreciate you taking my call sure
what's up
so i'm 26 my wife's 27
in january of this year we recently
became debt-free including our temporary
house
it's a mobile home we're living in we're
planning to build a home we have a
five-year plan hoping to save five
thousand dollars a month uh so that we
can build a three hundred thousand
dollar home
um
now that we're debt free we're kind of
getting into the investing portion
i'm investing 100 to 300 a week
through a cash management
account with fidelity along with maxing
out my roth through my employer
what portion of this is for the house
so the investing is is not for the house
neither neither one of those
no sir no sir um so
the the house we're putting in a savings
account five thousand a month at minimum
uh i'm in sales so sometimes we
contribute more than that
um
but additionally i'm maxing out my roth
uh with my employer
and then contributing one to three
hundred dollars a week
uh to the s p 500
but i heard you talking about doing a
roth ira
uh and didn't know if i was better off
doing that yes
at this stage at this stage of your
wealth building i would be putting 15 of
your income into retirement accounts in
raw and things that have matched first
things that are roth second and
traditional third
until you get to 15 what's your
household income a year
uh i'm about 260. good for you okay all
right so we're trying to get to about 50
000 bucks a year going into retirement
correct and uh
so you does your wife work outside the
home
uh she did she was a nurse practitioner
but we recently had twins so she's now a
stay-at-home mother okay cool
congratulations yeah that's wonderful
yeah so um gonna be tough to get to 50
000.
i mean you max out your 401k that's
going to be 20 and you max out your uh
two roths that's going to be another 16.
you're not going to still not going to
be there
it's only gonna be 36 so she's not
working anymore though i know you can do
a spousal roth anyway
um
but uh both of you do individual roths
in good gross stock mutual funds you max
out your 401k
uh in roth that's what i would do
and you know what at your stage of the
game how old are you guys
i'm 26 she's 27. that doesn't get you to
15 but that's all you can do without
doing after tax stuff and a cash
management type account instead what i
would do is build the house sooner i'd
throw everything above the fully funded
401 and the fully funded two roths
everything above that i throw in the
house account let's get this house built
in three years instead of five
so do i uh am i good saving the the
money or do i need to invest the house
fund and then no i wouldn't you're fine
saving it
just say that yeah on the house fund but
the other stuff needs to be in mutual
funds and in roths 401ks and two roth
individuals do that with a good smart
investor pro i mean you're putting 36
000 bucks away that way if i'm doing
that right in my head nice it's
32 000 but anyway
uh for the next three years that's
pretty substantial you make a lot of
money then you're gonna have a paid for
house very soon three to four years
something like that
and um
[Music]
then uh then you can worry about you'll
be a baby step seven you can worry about
other investing at that point
but uh you're doing great jack
great job well done incredible
patrick is in denver hey patrick what's
up
hey jv rachel how are you great how can
we help hey thanks for taking my call
i'm calling about taking an expensive
vacation this time next year to the
beach and want to know if i'm something
crazy for doing so um
a little background is me my wife and
two kids both on there too we go to the
beach for about two weeks half the time
we spent with my son in the family and
half the first time to the family
uh the total number of people at any one
time probably be about nine
uh these things are hard to plan so
essentially we're going to pay for the
house
and invite everyone um people have said
that they would contribute but not you
know no discussion with regard to how
much
um and so the budget that we're thinking
is it'd be about 20k for the house for
two weeks um and then i'm assuming about
three or five thousand
in extra spending uh you know for food
travel flights all that sort of stuff
what's your household income
so my wife and i from a salary
perspective we're about 300 a year
i'm heavily bonused um so all in we're
about 500 of 550 a year
and obviously you're paying cash for
this are you debt-free yep
uh everything but the
it i would do house
okay yeah
that's what that's within your ratios i
mean it's not crazy he told me you made
fifty thousand dollars a year i tell you
don't do it or if i if you told me you
were in debt you had three car payments
i tell you don't do it
but um okay i mean you make a half
million dollars a year you're dropping
20 grand
yeah well or my me and my wife were just
more conservative yeah but i mean if you
made 100 grand and you dropped four
grand it'd be the same thing
sure
got it ratio ratio it's the exact same
ratio right yeah the sticker price is
probably getting to you guys but yeah
but the but the thing to look at really
is the percentages of what you guys can
afford so when you see the sticker price
you're like 20 grand for a house oh my
gosh like it feels
feels like a lot because it's a lot but
you guys make a lot
and um generally
yeah as far as anybody else contributing
and all that kind of stuff i would have
zero expectation there
the secret to happiness is low
expectations
[Laughter]
yeah because if your wife is sitting
around waiting on somebody to chip in
then she's going to be pissed at them if
they don't
don't do this okay just don't worry
about it you don't have to if you you
don't need the money whatever they don't
chip in is good whatever they do chip in
is good whatever it's all good
awesome all right congratulations what
in the world do you do for a living
uh i'm in private equity
ah okay okay and what were you asking
rachel i just said enjoy the beach oh
which beach sounds great
right we will i'll wear my sunscreen too
what beach are you going to
uh it'd be in florida um near uh
pensacola yeah okay
dave and i might show up patrick we may
contribute we may not
we'll see sounds good
low expectations of us i'm not gonna say
a thing
[Laughter]
oh good luck with all that patrick it's
gonna work out
well done sir open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
so
ratios are a good way
to help you know if the amount is giving
you sticker shock or if you're being
irresponsible
and uh here's an example
a friend of mine made uh 20 million
dollars last year that's what he makes
most years somewhere in that range he's
very very very very successful makes a
lot of money
he bought a um
a 200 000 car
that's
mind-blowing right that's a lot
but
if you just take some zeros off let's do
it okay so instead of 20 million you
made 2 million instead of 200 000 you
bought a 20 000 car or 10 100 000.
now if you made if you went from 100 200
000 a year oh i'm sorry
from you went to a 200 000 car to a 20
000 car correct
zero off correct okay and you knock a
zero off the 20 million and so if you
make two million is it okay to buy a
twenty thousand dollar card yeah if you
make two hundred thousand
is it okay to buy a two thousand dollar
car it's exact same ratios
and if you make twenty thousand
is it okay to spend two dollars yep so
here's the here's the kicker though so
you look at the ratios which is really
really important but also gets to the
point of like when is the line of like
we just don't need it though yeah but
the point is it's not a relative amount
of money yes it's um you know when
someone
when he's making a half a million
dollars
spending 20 000 and again back your
ratios down what's that like for
somebody making 50 000
that's about like spending 200 bucks
totally yeah i mean it's the same thing
so is that irresponsible no can it shock
your mind because it feels like a lot
because you've never done it before
sure but none of you should stand to the
side and go no one should ever no that's
just you being a judgmental jerk that's
all that is this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 11 13
a gossip goes around telling secrets but
those who are trustworthy can keep a
confidence
eleanor roosevelt said great minds
discuss ideas average minds discuss
events and small minds discuss
people
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author is my co-host
today thank you for joining us america
we're so glad
you are here
mike is with us mike is in oklahoma city
hey mike welcome to the ramsey show
thank you sir thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
well i have been a dave ramsey follower
for years and i've gone through i'm a
baby all the way through baby seven
and would like to be able to start
giving back
and i have a heart for trying to help
new businesses get started
and i didn't know if you can give me
some guidance on what's the best way to
set up an organization whether it's
non-profit that type of thing to
put money into that i can get just give
away
how much are you talking about
the money to put into me i'm talking
maybe where i can give
oh like start helping companies
you know get maybe 15 to 25 000 to help
them get started that type of thing and
i'm looking to put in maybe
250 000 to get started that type of
thing okay all right
i think that's probably worthy of going
to the legal trouble to form a
foundation
okay former founder okay sit down with
an attorney and have a and talk about
how we put together a foundation
and um
we did that several years ago the ramsey
family foundation it's not for small
businesses it's for
ministries that we give to and support
and people and so forth um but uh
the same concept and you would apply for
and receive a
uh
you'd want to be a 501c3
a non-profit uh and um
it's an irs process to get that approved
uh takes a little while six weeks used
to i don't know with them not working
much now how that's gonna be but um
the uh
uh and then you've just got to put
together some you don't have to do this
legally but from a practical standpoint
you just need to think about how you're
going to
distribute the money in the most
efficient way that causes the most lift
right okay then right
are you plugging in this certain kind of
programs are you going to have
requirements or guidance guidance
guidelines for what type of small
businesses or they have to be healthy
and this way and that way in this way
before you do it or
um or is this just straight up startups
or
it's basically i was looking at startups
or ones that have just gotten started
i've done one already and i just did it
out of my pocket and they now expanded
they have it's a restaurant now have two
stores
and so i my i thought and i'm just you
know and i've been in church and you run
across and you hear different things i'm
thinking i would like to be able to help
out and start this or help them do that
and i just but i've just not been in a
position to start until now so
i mean you can continue to do it out of
your pocket but if you run it through
the 501 then
um it's a little more paperwork a little
more structure but you get you get the
tax deduction that way and uh and you
know it's formed for the purpose of this
and
um you know you know you'll need to get
legal and tax advice on how to put all
that together but it's it's not it's not
horrendous it's doable but it's not
worth it if you're going to give away
ten thousand dollars one time
it's not worth the trouble uh
and uh but in this case i you know 250
000 bucks and sounds like you've done
very well congratulations yeah and so if
you're giving out of that to get the tax
benefit do you have to give to other
501c3 no no
you know once your foundation is formed
for that purpose
then you're just supporting small
businesses and yeah
that's what the whole purpose of the
nonprofit is
and um but you've got to establish it
that way and it has to all be approved
of course
um
then the money that goes into the
foundation is tax deductible not the
money that comes out
so um as you put the money in you take
the tax deduction so when we fund
the ramsey the ramsey family foundation
that's a deductible process and i think
mike too just on a kind of a different
point but i'm like i would have maybe
three or four questions that you just
ask yourself to kind of run through and
if there's a no on one of those
questions it could be a red flag just to
give you some
a little bit of parameters too as you're
discussing this because also if this
kind of gets out
in the world
you may get some people knocking on your
door being like hey we
heard you did this over here and we want
to start this thing you know what i mean
so like having a little bit of guidance
just for yourself for sanity purposes i
think is important too so
we've definitely got had had to put that
in place and have put that in place in
hours
so that um because we you know we're
very restrictive on what we do give to
um
very careful
uh and yeah lots of guidelines on it
actually roger is with us rogers in
nashville hi roger welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you dave and rachel i appreciate
you taking my call sure what's up
well i'm recently i'm 65 years old my
wife will be 60 in december i'm recently
retired and
i met that dilemma of do you take social
security and i have a 403 b
account that has taken quite a hit over
the past
year or so
and trying to make a decision if i'm
supposed to tackle that or just get
another job to get me to 66 and a half
at the full
of the fruition of my social security
have no idea what to do
yeah
well you shouldn't have to how much is
in the 403 b
uh it's about 175 000. okay well you
wouldn't have to take out much to
uh to survive between now and then but
if you want to go and start social
security it's okay
um but you don't have anything to live
on basically is what you're saying
i don't and that's my dilemma should i
go get another job just to get me to 66
and a half
or should i go ahead and just start
taking the social security now or should
you draw down enough on the 175 because
you're not going to draw the whole thing
out
no no what's it take you to live a year
um well my income has been about 65 000
for me and my wife is about 38 000 but
so i'm at zero so we have her 38 and so
that leaves me should i get another job
or tap into both social security and
then and the uh
the retirement account yeah
well if this is all the nest egg that
you have it won't hurt to not touch it
and uh uh you know to work a little bit
more and get yourself through to where
you can get the money coming in to live
on that's gonna be good
it's not 1.7 million it's 175 000 yeah
so yeah i'm probably going to work in
that situation
um
seems like it's a wise thing to do
and then get yourself in a position that
that um you get everything organized get
the house paid off if it's not we're 100
debt free we're going in then we can
make it on
social security at that point and uh and
or a little bit of draw off of the
the nist egg that 175 will double about
every seven years that you don't touch
it if it's in good growth stock mutual
funds averaging what the stock market
has averaged
including all these i think that's
what's so hard too is people just like
in his position that are so close to
retirement
and it's like the hit over the last two
years it's like oh man it feels it feels
defeating
well it's not as bad as the news reports
i mean
he probably had 200 in there now he's
got 175 or something it's not like it
went in half yeah it did not go in half
but
it but it's fear
but to his point it's the worst time to
take it out right you don't want to take
it out at the bottom right or any of it
even enough to live on so
and uh and since it's not a huge nest
egg
then yeah i'm probably going to work and
leave the nest egg preserved
and not mess with social security right
now and go ahead and max it out
the social security formula is pretty
simple
it's very easy to do if you know when
you're going to die
because it dies with you and so the
longer you wait to take it the more you
get
but
the shorter you live the less that works
so um i mean if you wait till 66 and a
half you get the maximum amount but then
if you only live to 70 that doesn't work
out
uh and so if you
you know if if you kind of
have longevity in your family and so
forth you want to wait to take it unless
you have health problems that indicate
you're not going to enjoy the same
benefit so that's what you're facing
rachel good show today yes thanks for
having me on well done james andrew zach
ben and austin in the booth
the dudes in the booth
that's what we're going to start calling
the booth dudes oh wow that puts us this
hour in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
you